right now we've been seeing a huge
increase from
people ordering stuff off of the dark
web the dark web is a criminal flea
market
anyone with the internet can access
there was a big website back in the day
silk road
my understanding is that was taken down
but there are other versions of it you
can purchase drugs
weapons stolen credit card numbers and
virtually anything illegal on this
marketplace
they can go on the website they can
create fake ip addresses
the demand is here
anything that you buy on the dark web
has a potential to be the most dangerous
drug out there
you might think that you're buying
ecstasy and it could be fentanyl
you don't know what it is
[Music]
so
sprinkles for ice cream
oh it's a good one but one's coming out
we noticed some anomalies on the x-ray
could be coffee could be pills
[Music]
pills from spain two packages from the
same sender
approximately the same quantity in each
one
i'm gonna have to take it inside and use
a field test kit
this is a test kit for mdma and ecstasy
positive result should be very dark blue
to black
dark blue positive tests
take it over and wait
[Music]
we called hsi and the agents will be
here shortly
to pick these up for a possible control
delivery
we've seen a number of these going to
numerous locations throughout the united
states
some of them going to new york some of
them going to vegas
[Music]
hey chip how you doing got two going to
new york
perfect appreciate your help thank you
[Music]
you